it was pretty damn impressive i'm sure
when i watch the tape it'll even look
better um you know that play that he
made on the interception was one of the
more impressive plays i've seen from a
d-lineman um i thought he should have
scored but it's always it's always nice
when they don't and they let the offense
score too so i'm sorry
so i got kyle shanahan heaping praise on
nick bosa defensive rookie of the year
so far richard sherman has made the case
for nick boson to be defensive player of
the year he was dominant on
sunday three interceptions three sacks
and an interception three interceptions
would have been horrible three sacks and
an interception of nick bosa okay it's
sunday statement draft time i've got the
trivia question to determine the first
pick in the draft chris and here is the
question
russell wilson is in his eighth season
and through his 213th touchdown pass on
sunday only two quarterbacks in the
history of the national football league
have thrown more touchdowns in their
first eight seasons name one of them
oh aaron rodgers wow no darn it he was
on the bench oh three seasons totally
dummy you're right yeah peyton manning
dan marino dammit that was so easy you
were saying and i knew it was peyton
manning too and i just went with aaron
rodgers because it was in last night ah
three seasons on the bench yeah make it
hard to throw 213 in your first eight
years yes all right i get the first pick
you know i i was going to go nick bosa
but we just talked about nick bo so let
me go kevin coleman okay
four touchdowns for tevin coleman a
hundred yards rushing now it helped that
matt breida got banged up a little bit
but tevin coleman is a guy we just kind
of forgot about right but but
this was the guy remember in atlanta he
was the backup to devante freeman but
kyle shanahan loved him got an
opportunity to get him went and got him
and now he is a heck of a weapon for
that 49ers
multi-faceted multi-headed run game
right yeah most teams need a workhorse
they don't they just plug and play and
off they go and it's amazing that he's
gotten these guys who are selfless who
buy into the system who know the system
who know the playbook and coleman knows
it from his time in atlanta yes and
coleman coming in and making an impact
with four touchdowns on the game uh
which uh played big in that 51-13 route
yeah i know i mean they're missing their
starting right tackle they're missing
their fullback and use check i mean but
it is it's kind of running back by
committee and you don't know where
they're gonna hit you next between him
brita you know some of the the cool you
know we saw the debo samuel whatever you
want to call that fake toss inside
handoff to the wide receiver who runs up
the middle of the field uh shanahan on
fire with run game design and then he's
got some talented guys that can that can
run with the rock and all that money
they paid to jerick mckinnon yeah when
he became a free agent out of minnesota
he hasn't even played a game now he's
never made it to the start of a regular
season and they still are getting it
done impressively in the run game don't
think that's going to happen i don't
know if we'll ever see jarrett mckinnon
really with the 49ers at this point
they're kind of set at their running
back position all right i mean my i'm
gonna go with drew brees is my my first
statement i mean hey i mean johnny thumb
exercise he showed us why he was doing
all those damn thumb exercises on tv and
everything i mean he was to be able to
come back and just go
oh yeah no big deal i'll go 34 for 43
for 373 and three touchdowns i mean just
amazing i mean it really is you know i
don't care if you're drew brees peyton
manning john elway whoever it is when
you miss five or six weeks of football
usually you come back with a little rust
and i mean he just seemed like it was
you know just another sunday and he'd
been out here the whole year and nothing
had ever happened i'm just amazed by
that uh in general he's just so accurate
with some of the short to intermediate
passes like on this play here gives
michael thomas just the chance to run
after the catch uh can just dissect you
with his brain and knowing where to go
with the football but uh i think he
reminded us everybody that you know hey
teddy bridgewater is really good but
we're a little bit better when drew
brees is in there and the saints are
certainly a more scary super bowl
contender with drew brees at the helm
yeah you know michael thomas told me
after the game there's no difference
when it's drew brees or teddy
bridgewater on the field that's the
mentality but he said i never take for
granted being in the huddle with a hall
of fame quarterback freezes back and the
saints never went away 5-0 without him
impressive on sunday with him and now
they have two weeks to get ready for
their next game which is a visit from
the atlanta falcons all right uh next
one for me boy i can go a lot of
different directions here i i i think i
would like to go
with cooper cup okay i'm impressed by
what cooper cup did sure in london you
sound like you're from london 220
receiving yards through two and a half
quarters they stopped going to him but
this guy is just quietly becoming one of
the best receivers in the nfl not flashy
coming and you know when you have that
torn acl they say it takes all uh uh two
years before you're back to who you are
he toured the asl last year he's been
great this season with brandon cooks now
suffering his fourth concussion since
super bowl 52 cup may have to become the
guy in that passing attack and if the
rams are going to pull themselves back
into this race in the nfc west or at a
minimum for a wild card berth because
they're on the outside looking in right
now they're going to need more
performances from guys like cooper cup
so cup very very impressive in london
they went over on friday uh it didn't
matter they stayed in atlanta all week
yeah it's just a well-oiled machine and
you know they lost those three games in
a row and and a lot of us wanted to just
write them off they're going to be a
factor they're going to be a factor down
the stretch and again it's a hell of a
game of musical chairs in the nfc
because there's going to be one or two
or three great teams that don't get in
yeah it is and and you're i mean the
rams you know again
just this is the way they're going to
have to win this year that's what you're
seeing i think more than anything to
your point with cooper cup and
phenomenal day he had yesterday you know
jared goff and the passing game are
going to have to win it the rams are not
the run team that we've seen the last
two years when they went to the super
bowl the year before that when they lost
on the nfc wild card game they were
really truly run game and you know
during that time i was looked at as the
jared goff hater because everyone's like
he's a top five quarterback and i was
like whoa pump the brakes he's not but
now they lose a few games this year and
everyone's like oh jared goff he's not
good he's below average no that's not
true either so i i fight that stupid
narrative jared goff is really good
quarterback you know he's somewhere for
me outside the top ten but they're gonna
have to continue to rely on him to win
football games because they're not gonna
be able to run the ball it doesn't look
like this year and i even thought
through the three losses other than the
49er game who the 49ers gonna make a lot
of people look ugly and i don't care who
was that quarterback that day it wasn't
going to be easy golf has played pretty
damn good football and i give him credit
there all right my next pick the
philadelphia eagles i'm going with a
full team because that was a full team
statement what they did up in buffalo
yesterday i mean i wanted to talk about
the o-line and the run game and okay
yeah great but damn their defense was
dominant too and to go up to buffalo we
know it's a tough place to play the
bills yes you know
six or five and one going into the
matchup one of the best defenses in
football
um the eagles just made it happen as a
team in general one
causing a turnover you know on josh
allen's little quarterback design run i
think it was on like a third and two or
a third and three he runs it out to the
right they strip them ball comes out you
know wentz throws a touchdown to dallas
goddard a few plays later and the game
never really seemed to be the same from
that point on but i think the eagles
their their defensive front dominated
the football game in a lot of ways their
offensive line dominated the the the the
trenches and the run game and uh they
made a statement to say watch out
because if we play like this they're
going to be a team to be reckoned with
once again in the nfc i mean i'm
impressed by the fact that the eagles
play so well when their backs are
against the wall but i'm busy
disheartening
that they don't play better
until their backs are against the wall
right right and they had all this other
stuff that that you know was was closing
in on them and they have the comments
from orlando scandrick and dysfunction
malcolm jenkins and carson wentz and
unnamed sources and doug peterson last
week with the guarantee that wasn't a
guarantee and they got splattered by the
cowboys i wish it didn't have to take
it to that point where you know yeah i
would have liked it better if you made a
specific like there's plenty of choices
of somebody from the team who made a
statement yeah well i don't care what
you like this is my pick and you can
shove it i don't like you so you care
about that does it bother you that i
don't like you no because i know you do
[Laughter]
all right here's a guy i like and uh i
know the jaguars fans like him gardner
the ginsu minshu yeah you know they lose
you know he was hot early and then they
lose a game or two and we forget about
look minshew was great yesterday and
yeah it's just the jets but
gardner-minshew's a six-round rookie who
was thrust into the fray week one and
now we're getting close to the point
where nick foles is gonna be ready to go
and doug maron the coach of the jaguars
said today he's not worrying about the
decision until he has to and that
basically fits with what i was told
yesterday that they're trying to kick
this can as long as they can they don't
want to have to make a decision there
are business reasons
to put nick foles on the field they gave
him a lot of money sure and they're
already paying blake board they didn't
pay black borders a lot of money this
year they paid him a lot of money last
year they're taking the cap hit this
year right and they don't have bortles
they're gonna have the cap hit and the
money given to nick foles and he's gonna
be standing on the sideline but minshew
what a bargain a six-round pick on a
rookie wage skill contract for three
years and they're making money off of
them they love him in jackson yes they
do i mean you know you need to get
people to be willing to show up and
every once in a while when we're
watching the games on sunday we see the
wide shot of the stadium
it looked like more people in
jacksonville than i'm used to seeing in
jacksonville at a jaguars game well he
brings an exciting brand of football i
mean you know do i think it's a little
overblown and over hyped at times just
because of his mustache and you know the
way he looks yes i do but yesterday was
not one of those moments i mean he made
some plays yesterday uh and
part of the reasons they had you know a
good day offensively was because of him
and his talents and and of course they
have a really good running back in
leonard fournette uh man okay i'm not
sure where i want to go i think my i
want to go like adam vinatieri because
he still made a statement but i think
i'm gonna go with matt stafford okay we
haven't talked about that game and matt
stafford played phenomenal and just for
everybody out there matt stafford's
played phenomenal the whole year he's
playing like one of the best
quarterbacks in football and you know we
talk about the culture change he had to
adjust to last year and everything well
he's adjusted this year and with them
going through the running running game
but his his ability still is top notch i
mean this is one of the greater greatest
throwers we've ever seen in the nfl and
he's been on fire he's been playing
really good football you know completion
percentage yards touchdowns whatever he
is helping this team and makes them
dangerous and yeah they're not one of
the most talented teams in the nfc but
he he gives them a chance to compete or
beat anybody on a given sunday because
of his talents and the way he's playing
right now and that wasn't an easy win
for the lions because they had a week of
dysfunction they traded quandary diggs
multiple guys were upset about it darius
slay ended up inactive for the game he
would not let it go
this was a test of the ability of matt
patricia to get this situation under
control reverse a three-game losing
streak they did well they trade him
he's apparently on the block now i would
think so i mean i would think the eagles
might be calling him right now the
eagles might be calling detroit well and
and here's the thing you got to ask
yourself can you and every coach thinks
i can manage a guy right who was
previously unmanageable i can do it
nobody else can i can or i don't need to
manage him this year i just need to get
through the season with some help and
he'll be fine this year it won't be
until next year that we have to really
try to manage darius slay but he could
be available and plenty of guys
potentially available as we get closer
and closer to the trade deadline coming
up tomorrow at 4 p.m eastern
kevin coleman cooper cup gardner minshew
my choices drew brees the entire eagles
organization yes everybody ticket
the people who saw the ball
and then matthew stafford
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports